to call a terror group is it possible to
have a rational I've asked you two
questions should Hass stay in power and
are they a terror group you're refusing
to answer either of them that is very
telling talk TV is the only place where
you get the truth you've done a book on
poetry poetry and music for the many I
love poetry we can agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on psor censor Mary hers is
crowned Sports perative of a year after
winning absolutely nothing in 2023 is
celebrating mediocrity or losing making
Britain a nation of losers will debate
the poll show Donald Trump is on c for a
stunning return to the White House in
defiance of his legal wo now one state
sensationally ruled he should be struck
from the ballot are the legal attacks on
Trump making him even more popular and
likely to win th Benjamin Netanyahu vows
that Israel will not stop until Hamas is
completely wiped out as the Hamas run
health authority in Gaza claims 20,000
people have now been killed has Israel
already gone too far Dr Cornell West
joins me Li to debate
[Music]
that
live from the news building in London
this is Pierce Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to appears
Morgan uncensor the sports Personality
of the Year award used to be Britain's
biggest celebration of sporting Swagger
it was the athletic Oscars a crown of
rry for the sporting superstars who
defied the odds thrilled Spectators and
rallied the nation all with a twinkle in
their eye and a cheeky grin past winners
included Rocket Man Sterling Moss World
Cup hero Bob Bobby Moore the audacious
Ian Botham the impossibly gifted Paul
gazer gascoin Lennox the lion Lewis
Golden Balls David Beckham and on it
went a veritable gilded Scroll of
indisputable greatness for all their
charm their hoods spur and yes
personality what all those winners had
in common is that they won a lot of
things but at last night's Ceremony this
happened and the winner of the 2023 BB D
sports Personality of the year
is From Nottingham Mary
herbs well look Mary hers is the
goalkeeper for the England Women's
National Team she seems a thoroughly
decent human being with bags of
Personality she's also an excellent
women's goalkeeper uh playing for
England uh at the peak of her career uh
but this year was not the best for her
or lionesses they lost the World Cup
finals to Spain uh more people talked
about The Unwanted advances of Lewis
rubiales from the Spanish Football
Association another thing that the is
did on the pitch and milanes has then
failed to qualify for the Olympic Games
this is really a year where they want to
just keep quiet isn't it rather than go
out there and accept awards for being
the best sports person in the country
those who missed out this year on
winning were Frankie Dori the greatest
jockey in history as he retired rder cup
hero roor maroy one of our greatest ever
golfers Cricket Legend Stuart broad who
ended a spectacular career on an
incredible high and won the moral ashes
and what about Rono Sullivan who won his
eighth World Snooker Championship a
record and wasn't even
nominated well students of my Common
Sense assessments of such things will
recall I was equally scathing when the
England men's team won Team of the Year
in 2020 despite having lost the Euro's
final to Italy the great Kenny dowlish
who won eight League titles and three
European cups as a player and manager
was given a Lifetime Achievement Award
and he said this but for me it's it's
about it's not about taking part that's
a bit winning yeah it's not about taking
part it's not about participation prizes
it's about winning that's what made
Kenny Dow gash one of the greatest
winners in the history of British sport
it's quite literally the definition
isn't it of sport you compete to win now
we've now had three female winners of
the BBC sports Personality award on the
bounce and to be clear there's nothing
wrong with women winning the title Emma
rakano shocked the world to win the US
Open age 18 a worthy winner Beth me led
the lionesses to an historic European
championship title last year a worthy
winner and in previous years Dame Kelly
Holmes won two gold medals at the Summer
Olympics and she won it good so she
should but Mary hers this year won
nothing even her Club Manchester United
rather like the men's version won
absolutely nothing she did lead a
virtuous campaign to have replicas of
the women's goalkeeping shirt made
available to buy okay does that meet you
the sports Personality of the year over
Rory maroy Stuart broad Frankie Dori
Paul Rono
Sullivan does it does it even make you
better winner than K Katarina Johnson
Thompson who won a second hethlon gold
in the world championships Athletics I
don't think so it looks to me like that
terrible scourge of virtue signaling box
ticking has crept in to this once great
award it's become the national
equivalent of a participation medal
didn't they all do well losing doesn't
matter winning would have been a problem
this is where we've gone isn't it we're
a society that now celebrates mediocrity
over winning and when you do that your
Society becomes inevitably mediocre
itself which is exactly how so many
British people feel right now about our
country and our place in the world well
j i to discuss all this is sports
broadcaster Bianca Westwood talked to
the contributor Esther krku of Del
mirror's associate editor Kevin Maguire
right right Bianca Westwood you and I uh
discussed uh recently Joey Barton's
comments about women pundits and
commentators and I was with you on that
I thought he was talking a loot of
nonsense actually about uh about the
women's commentary and punditry lineup
many of whom are absolutely excellent
and just as good by the way as many of
the men if not better right which is how
it should be you're there on Merit
you're not there because you're a woman
on this one I have a big problem I can
see that with what happened because I
think it sends entirely the wrong signal
I don't understand why she won other
than it's a public vote so a load of
women I presume and girls who love the
lionesses have
gone and she wins but she's not a worthy
winner it doesn't do women's sport any
good it doesn't do women any good the
number of women you've messaged me
honestly and said you're so right we
don't want to win like this we don't
want to win just because we're women we
want to win because we win or we're as
good or better than the men what's wrong
with that did you vote
no well if you cared so much about it I
don't vote in any public vot why didn't
you vote ever since the British public
voted to name a boat voting boat face I
realized they couldn't be trusted right
I don't really have a leg to stand
on I don't vot anything all of those on
social media are so angry to be clear I
don't they didn't vote I don't think
it's my right as a uh supposedly
impartial television presenter of a news
and current affairs show Dev V voote in
any of these things I don't right so
let's just park that to one side all
right well there's a few key elements
that here's my question did she deserve
to win Prince William was on Twitter
today saying hugely welld deserved Mary
signed w why was it hugely welld
deserved she deserved it as much as
anybody else short list what did she win
you have to look at the criteria first
of all I actually didn't know what the
criteria for the sports Personality was
so I looked it up up it's says it takes
into consideration the sporting
achievements of the last 12 months and
the impact of those achievements beyond
the sportting question I think that's
key but if you want to look at Mar Up's
achievements she was the only loser of
the seven nomin I tell you what she did
win she won the World Cup Golden Glove
the fa player of the year the FIFA
Women's world's best goalkeeper England
women's player of the year the WSL
Golden Glove as well she won that she
was a World Cup finalist she won the
final isma she also won the Arnold Clark
Cup as well which is another inter how
many actual compe another International
how many competitions for CP country did
win if any England male player had won
any of those or and especially if they'd
won all of them I don't think we'd be
having this discussion really no I don't
if Jordan P Jordan pford had won the
best goalkeeper in the world the fa best
player of the the season uh the Golden
Glove in a World Cup the Golden Glove in
the Premier League league if he'd have
won all those would we be having this
discussion right now do you genuinely in
your heart believe that she is a worthy
winner than Rory maroy who's never won
it Ronnie O Sullivan who's never won it
Frankie even on the short list for some
reason Frankie dor has never won it
Stuart brao one of the alltime Greg
cricketers never won it none of these
guys have ever won it Ronnie wasn't even
nominated but it takes into
consideration the sporting achievements
of the last 12 months I don't know when
they make the short list maybe it was
before Ronnie had won the the UK that's
a different argument I'm not sure why he
wasn't on there but it's also about the
impact and you can't say that Mary hers
doesn't have an impact in her that's
interesting point so my daughter comes
home from school today age 12 you know
the first thing she said to me Yer she
said D she said I I had a great G of
football today I went what proper one
she proper one I said what with with
girls she said girls and boys I said
what happened she we won and I said
where did you play she said we sender
Midfield deam rice I was like wait I
love this so I I completely love the
impact the lionesses have had on the
nation's females young and middle age
and old whatever they want to be to play
football to watch football to love
football great right that's not for me
in debate it's great is that enough to
Warrant winning this well I think
obviously the answer is no but I think
you're bigger issue was with voting
British public as opposed to the fact
that she's on the short list because yes
of course there are the people that want
it but it's who's more visible right
this this woman is is is in in a
position of prominence particularly for
young girls who probably have never
voted for this they thought actually
this might be the first year I'll vote
for this woman so I think that's the
bigger issue I do take issue with the
quip though about Manchester United Mr
Pierce Morgan and I will never forget
that as as a traumatized United fan I
remember it wasn't a quip it was a
statement of fact You've Won absolutely
nothing and you're not going to because
you got rid of Ronaldo and ever since
then you've collapsed and Eric ten
turned out to be completely I need I
need some mental health uh resources Qui
it was a statement of fact I yes but I'm
de I'm deeply hurt by it the can be hurt
recovering from my illness well then
don't drive Ronaldo out of your car
right uh Kevin give me some common sense
take on this P look I'd have voted for
Steward broad but you didn't Wing back
the ashes he won the moral ashes yeah
but he didn't win back the ashes he
cheated does he he didn't win back the
the ashes the fact is hers has got bags
of Personality she sells more shirts
than Jordan Pigford the male England
keeper and it's a sports Personality
well she qualifies for sport and she's
got the person the last loser who didn't
win anything I mean look
iide the individual Golden Gloves that's
all fine right you know but when was the
last person who actually was a loser in
a year to win that award well the ones I
know think of Gaza Gaza won in 1990
England didn't even get the World Cup
final I thought he was a worthy winner
1998 uh Owen Michel Owen won it England
didn't get to the final look she got to
the final she won the Golden Gloves
she's inspired people like your daughter
and that's why she won all those people
it must be tens hundreds of thousands of
women have been inspired to play
football because of the likes of her
that's why she's I think my irritation
about it is that I think the others was
are such worthy winners and in terms of
Personality there is no bigger
personality in World sport than Frankie
Dori for example Ronnie O Sullivan the
documentary about his life is
unbelievable right he's won eight World
titles and never won this right um you
know you look at Stuart broad I mean one
of the all-time great cricketers you
could go through a whole list of them
it's really the one the men who haven't
won it now being eclipsed by somebody
from the same team as the winner last
year and yet this year the team did very
badly to me it looks like a reward for
failure I do take your point I mean I
knew that not everyone had won so I was
curious whether you knew and there a
valid point to make the points you make
about all the individual things she's
picked up is a valid point to make the
impact she's had on the game is a valid
point to make but no one can convinced
me that this year those men that were
eclipsed shouldn't have won it in state
that right they have achieved more in
their careers and questionably however
they've had long careers so in in a
sense you don't get the impact she has
got because women's football is taken
off that's abely it's like a volcano
erupting and that's why people have gone
but that's why they were rightly honored
last year with almost every honor going
including the team award but they also
won the individual personality of the
year which was the I think she was the
captain right right Beth perfectly good
to do that I just think it when you
start rewarding people for the failure
of their team to win anything which is
really what this world done that's not
what they're rewarding her for they're
rewarding her for being an exceptionally
good female football player who is
inspiring people that's that's why
they're she could argue that she's
having more impact on young people than
any of those other Sportsman you know
Ronnie as brilliant as he is is is he
inspiring uh you know an a generation of
young kids pick up the failure of a
football player to not win anything is
down to the team as opposed to her as an
individual so we have to remember that
one thing I think we can agree on is
Joey Barton in his in his rant today
something which I agree with but in his
rant today he says he he said I'll score
eight aund out of a 100 penalties
against Mary herbs any day of the week
twice on a Sunday here's my challenge to
Joey B right you do that let's set that
up you take a 100 penalties against her
right and every one you miss you give a
100,000 pound to a charity of our choice
he' be bankrupt 100 Grand per Miss
penalty right I reckon he'd be down a
few million right she's a good
goalkeeper right but the thing we can't
agree on he also said that he also was
personally abusive and said that she was
a sack of Spuds or something right she's
obviously a great athlete She's
supremely Fit she's at the top of her
game playing in World Cup finals and so
that kind of gratuitous abuse I think is
completely unacceptable and unnecessary
right so we can all agree on that that's
very different though uh to questioning
as you are why has she won when these
Sports people have over their careers
achieve I think Joey Barton is look he
just needs to get a life or get another
manager's job or a partner or whatever
whatever he just he's just again I he's
like a teenage boy enjoying the
attention from the internet for the
first time you know that high where
you're just incentivized to say whatever
comes to your mind I mean I think the
bigger issue with this award is should
she have been nominated in the first
place for not actually having won
anything I don't think it's the fact
that she won I nomination I think I
think that's a good point yeah I think
it's the nomination not the fact that
she won because last year everyone no
one had any problem with Beth me wi it
because they won the Euros fantastic
right but I just think that I'm not sure
that women should feel comfortable about
this win I think women should think you
know what this looks like box ticking
but then you have to look at the
criteria what have the others won in the
last 12 months it was propelled by a
bunch of young
women never been interested in women's
football the driving for find the
winning the rer cup the one of the
biggest sporting events in the world R
Ma has never won this if if england mans
football he didn't win an individual
major this year he won he won the
Ultimate Team event if if if england
men's football got the World Cup final
Jordan pford Sunland lad played Blinder
all the way through best Keeper in the
game they lose one nil and he won it
would you really well you know well you
know I've already said that when we when
we lost the Euro's final I didn't think
men have won the team award but you
waxed lyrical about Gaza who was you
know an unbelievable player but in 1990
he hadn't won a thing why is that okay
because he's Gaza yeah he was Gaza he
was Gaza and he cried in Italy and
that's why he won it DAV a more talented
a free kick you against Greece that was
why he tell because he was the greatest
footballer English footballer I don't
think Ryan I've ever seen and with
greatest respect to Mary she wouldn't
get into gaza's junior team scho right
so let's be clear it's in your chosen
field we're not be clear about saying
that wom football is if you're going if
you're going to compare men to that's
like saying cycling is the same as
Athletics you if you're going to say
best sport if you're going to compare
her to Gaza I'm going to say Gaza was
not
only best their field Not only was Gaza
10 times better as a football player he
just was but secondly he had 10 times
the impact on the country right and if
you don't believe me go out and ask a
100 people in the street tomorrow go
down down on the street ask them two
questions who's Paul gascoin and then
say who is Mary herbs abut and even
though she's just won that award most of
them won have know heard of mar hers
right I agree I'm not saying that they
won't in 5 10 years the growth of the
game is fantastic nobody knew please
don't try and compare her to Gaza no but
no I was saying that because you had
said that you had to have won something
he hadn't won anything that year that's
a Val point he cried in Italy that is a
valy point and we all felt for him
both both B gas in 1990 Mike alone in 98
didn't win but they inspired people
Mar done the same again that's it it's
the well can only judge again if my
daughter's out playing football at Dean
rice and Senter Midfield and ecstatic
about it something's happening
something's happening and I like it and
I like it so uh Maybe I'm Wrong Maybe
I'm Wrong maybe you persuaded me good
put you know what you put up a very good
defense thanks which doesn't surprise me
because you're very capable but anyway I
appreciate it all thank you very much
indeed on sensor next Donald Trump's
been kicked off the ballot by the
Supreme Court in Colorado will it only
make him stronger yet another bombshell
day in US politics I'm joined by the
mighty Tyrus after
[Music]
the we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and she soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or fav the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a livit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man M
mouseman he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast
reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you to call terror group is it possible
to have a rational I've asked you two
questions should aass stay in power and
are they a terror group you're refusing
to answer either of them that is very
telling talk TV is the only place where
you get the truth you've done a book on
poetry poetry and music for the many I
love purgy we can agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to stand the landmark
ruling Colorado Supreme Court says that
Donald Trump cannot run for president in
the state next year starting a
constitutional Insurrection Clause over
the January 6th riots critics say it's
just the lest example of the open
lawfare that's been launched against
Trump most of which seems to help him so
will this like all his other indictments
uh and the infamous mug shot just make
him more popular more likely to win well
joining me to discuss this and much more
as the author of the brilliant new book
n said Fox news commentator and former
wrestling Superstar tus tus great to see
you how are
you happy holidays Merry Christmas
always great to see you not in person
this time but I'll take it well I look
forward to seeing you soon in person but
um I'm going to come to your brilliant
book and it is a brilliant book I I had
a pleasure of one night in New York
going through your life story with you
for about an hour one of the most
extraordinary stories I think I've heard
in a long time so I'm so pleased you put
a lot of that in writing so we'll come
to that let's just talk first of all
before we get to Trump we were just
having a debate about uh the BBC sports
Personality of year world going to a
woman uh soccer player as she would be
called in America who didn't actually
win anything with either the England
team or her Club side this year and beat
a lot of people who did what do you
think of that are we rewarding too much
mediocrity when we do that kind of thing
does it help women to win something like
that with a public vote when they
haven't won
something well I think well in America
if the fact that she's a biological
woman winning an award for uh Athletics
is is a great thing because it's you
know we're we're experiencing some
different things here I think when you
get into Awards now you have to look at
who's paying what publicist you know
that's the one thing I learned because I
assumed getting into late night comedy
and stuff that would be up for an Emmy
every year but it doesn't work that way
even if you're number one uh if you're
not paying the fees and doing the right
things or appeasing the right people you
don't get Awards so I don't put much
faith in Awards anymore so um you know
the if the best athlete of the year
should be the one with the most rings on
at the end of the year or the best
performance or the best you know most
outstanding that's the what the reason
why you have athlete of the Year Have We
Become a society ter world we live in
now yeah I was going to ask you have we
become a society that now you know
almost promotes losing above winning
that there's a kind of Valor in Failure
because then you can virtue sign about
it play the victim get all the sympathy
it seems to we're moving that way that
in the old days it used to be you won or
you lost now it's like oh you came lost
great How
brave not just that but you're 100%
right but the other thing is like you're
taking away you want everyone it's more
of a socialist way of looking at things
where you know capitalism is e evil
because those who work the hardest and
and work the longest tend to win and the
same thing with sports sports is the
most discriminat easy way to call it the
best athlete wins you can't lie in the
numbers and stuff so you have to offset
that by saying well we picked someone
who deserved it because we we just feel
like they should do it and when you're
dealing with feelings instead of
Statistics uh you're always going to end
up with these weird uh situations where
people who clearly didn't deserve the
best person didn't win uh and they'll
say well you know he's misogynistic or
you know she's not being feminist enough
those things should have absolutely
nothing to do when it comes to sports
but we're seeing unfortunately Sports
has has been infected with this feelings
propaganda uh that we're seeing abroad
you know in just the Western world alone
it's just it's a really weird time right
now it's it absolutely is um it's also a
weird time politically um Donald Trump
obviously roaring away the head of the
Republican nominee polling to be the
nominee uh and this extraordinary
development overnight with the Colorado
Supreme Court ruling he can't run for
president in the state because of the uh
actions that they said represented an
Insurrection ahead of the January 6th
Riot now it's important to note this
will probably get overthrown by the
federal Supreme Court but not
withstanding that the fact that a state
supreme court has done this without
Trump actually being convicted of any
crime in relation to January 6th yet I
mean he might be but he hasn't been as S
stand what does that tell you about uh
the state of politics in America and
indeed the law
well it it's scary because In America
which was the whole place was supposed
to be founded on justice for all but and
you know even we have the statue with
the blindfold on well clearly the
blindfolds off now and it it depends on
if you see things the same way as the
judge that's over you so if I if I get
in trouble I hope that there is a uh
Republican voting judge who likes to
lift weights and there's a good chance
that maybe he'll see my side of things
as far as I know and I do work
technically at news station although not
a very newsy guy I think Trump being
arrested or convicted of insurrection
would be front page news so they're
they're saying he can't run because what
exactly was he convicted of yet as far
as I know and none of the charges have
anything to do with Insurrection which
I'm pretty sure is considered treason
which would be a pretty he'd have bigger
problems to worry about than whether he
was able to run for president so it's a
joke and you're 100% right their their
guy did it they knew it would probably
be over term but that's the problem in
itself there shouldn't be and and the
vote was I think it was two Republicans
and three Democrats that voted uh and
they just voting not off and the one
place you're supposed to be safe is in
courts it's supposed to be about the
rule of law uh and facts not how you
vote and how you feel in America it's
really a black eye on the justice system
that we're seeing left leaning right
leaning uh whatever your political po
politics is a new religion in America so
whatever your religion your politic
religion is uh the judge is going to see
your way and that's dangerous and scary
across the pond we're looking at the
American presidential election with a
kind of slightly raised British eyebrow
saying what is happening here on the one
hand you've got both eyebrows should be
raised yeah me you've got the incumbent
President Biden who is incredibly
unpopular record unpopularity and new
polls out this week um on almost every
metric two-thirds of Democrats don't
want him to run again he seems
determined to do so despite clearly you
know it his age and an obvious senility
if not even uh dementia is becoming a
laughing stock on the on the national
and Global stage so you've got Biden
determined to do it you've got Trump
facing nearly a hundred criminal charges
and we have no idea how those are all
going to play out other than at the
moment he's playing the victim the Marty
and it's working politically for him but
it mean just take yourself away from
that side show for a moment it's a big
sesh show that will become the main show
Can America not find new people who are
not 81 and 78 who are not have all this
baggage youve not got all these problems
you're one of the great countries of the
world 320 million people I talk to
people like you terus and I see such
energy and dynamism and Clarity of
thought and all these things where are
the
politicians that have that well well the
problem is and is because America we
have a real problem with term limits
when you have the Mitch McConnell and
the Nancy Pelosi where rep where
politicians is an establishment and it's
a money-making business what it turns
out for lawyers and people who weren't
very good at Wall Street but when you're
good at inside trading then all of a
sudden your family members become
Geniuses at it so America's got a real
problem with term limits we don't get uh
someone like a career politician is
probably one of the most crooked people
uh on the planet because you don't take
a job in service for that long at that
rate of pay and and up with Mansions it
just doesn't even even our most
socialist politician Bernie Sanders
ended up with two Mansions so I mean
even you know so the the corruption is
unbelievable they control who can get in
and get out the I would honestly say if
it wasn't for the attacks by the media
on President Trump he probably wouldn't
have ran again yeah but I think he
almost have to whether you support Trump
or not if you were ever in that
situation where you get you he was
elected and his entire presidency one
they tried to say he wasn't legitimate
he cheated with Russia they ran with
false Stories the entire time they ran
two impeachments they weren't concerned
with what it did to the country or
whatever they just ran and created this
monster and President Biden who couldn't
get elected in 50 years to be president
became president because he became don't
vote for Trump vote for me they didn't
vote for President Biden if you ask an
American any Democrat or anything ask
Bill Mah do you like President Biden
they'll be like well I like uh well you
know they because they don't and they're
going to try to do the same thing again
where it's it's fine that Biden can't
walk upstairs it's fine a betting man I
don't know if you're a betting man but
you were a Betty Manus who do you think
will be making not to your level but I
do bet I bet like 20s and tens not to
your level who would you think will be
making the inauguration speech in
January
2025 well I think it's going to be one
of those here's it's one or two things
one uh there'll be a representative for
incarcerated president Trump reading the
inauguration speech or or two there'll
be uh Camala reading for Biden because
he's exhausted so either way we're not
going to have either one whoever is PR
whomever is President uh is probably
will not be fit to be able somebody said
to me what do you think is going to
happen I said Trump will either end up
in prison or reelected or potentially
both because the Constitution would
allow him to be president even if he's
incarcerated um let's turn to your book
uh now say quickly um it's a it's a
terrific book because you and I agree
about so many things and all the hot
button issues that you talk about all
the woke nonsense all the cancell
culture uh you talk about three scams
you believe in the world today the black
lives matter uh the group behind it you
think is just a Hustle the concept of
reparations to black people you're very
strong about that you think it's just
ridiculous um on all those things I
think you're so such a you're such a
clear thinker but what was the
motivation do you think for you to get
to where you've got to to achieve what
you've achieved because I look at your
earli you know there was nothing in your
early life that could have said this guy
is going to go right to the top somehow
you fought your way literally there
um I think I never really liked failure
and I would listen to the people no was
always no you can't be that oh you can't
do that and and people love to tell me
what I couldn't do and I was just the
most hard-headed child if you tell me
I'm your spite I fed off spite spite was
like my Mutant power every time some I
was dyslexic oh you you're not going to
be really good at reading and and school
and stuff because you see things
backwards you're you know or oh man you
don't have a dad or you you this that
whatever you always have dirty clothes
at school cuz you wore the same two
outfits every day like anytime someone
instead of curling up in a ball it would
just tough me and be like watch you
watch what's going to happen bet and
that's really been a story in my life so
I always give thanks even in my book I
said you know there's supposed to be
acknowledgements and all that stuff and
I acknowledged pain loss and failure
because those are the three greatest
teachers in my life and I've been lucky
to have a lot of people across every
spectrum of color or or or sexuality
that have been helped me and might have
been listening there have been mentors
for me but the biggest thing was always
every time I failed I didn't spend too
much time on the failure it was more
about the looking up all right what's
I'm okay I can't go this door is closed
I'm going to find another door so I
think it was just my incessant need to
to to be better and I loved I just
enjoyed like one of the things I loved
about wrestling and football I love
playing on the road I love getting booed
at home and you do I see a little
twinkle in your eye exact you kind of
like that and I'd be like I know what
you cheer for your booze give me
self-esteem so I just never accepted the
word no and I think that's that's built
and uh I've always been willing to
Outsource and and seek knowledge if I
don't know something I don't just say
well I I feel like it's this way I will
go seek it seek it out and I think that
has served me well you see tus that is
why you and I get on so well because
that's exactly my outlook on life I
think you learn more from failure I
think I've had a lot of ups and downs in
my career and life and I've always used
it to fuel me to drive to the next thing
I think it's such an important quality I
see a epidemic of anxiety amongst kids
these days and I want to sit down with
all of them and say look this is normal
life stuff and how you deal with the
tough stuff is what defines the way you
lead your life it really is so you've
got to toughen up and here's how you're
going to do it and I tell you how they
should do it they should read your book
enough said if they read your book they
will understand what it takes to succeed
in life and how you overcome adversity
it's it's a brilliant book uh tus thank
you for lot L's always a pleasure man
appreciate you Merry Christmas give your
family my love and hopefully we'll see
get together soon I'll see you in New
York take care all the very
best well on says it next Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu says Israel
will not stop until Hamas is completely
eradicated what does that mean how long
will this go on what is the end game
what happens next Presidential
Challenger do Cornell West says he's a
war criminal he's live
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the t's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side side and richy soon had the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swearing Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy I needs
to be one human per machine to come and
rectify beeps and the clanks and when it
goes wrong unexpected item in bagging
area I know are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news to come from
at Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine is actually not
my job to answer your question are you
prepared to call a terror group is it
possible to have a rational you talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back to on sens Hamas says
the death toll in Gaza has now surpassed
20,000 people with nearly 2 million
others displaced from their often
destroyed homes or calls for permanent
ceasefire are growing ever louder in a
defiant speech today Benjamin Netanyahu
said Israel will not stop
should the US now back calls for a
ceasefire and could Israel face
sanctions for the scale of its response
October the 7th Jing discuss this is the
independent presidential candidate Dr
cor West and international law expert
Eugene korovich welcome to both of you
um Corno West great to have you back on
the program let me ask you first of all
uh Benjamin Netanyahu tonight very
unequivocal Israel will keep fighting
Hamas until they are
eradicated um which means there's going
to be months and months more of what
we've been seing uh what is your
response to
that well as you know I've called for
Netanyahu and IDF to be brought before
the IC international criminal court
article 67 and 8 crime of genocide crime
against humanity and War crime and what
I mean by that is we need to live in a
world in which we fundamentally believe
that Palestinian suffering has the same
value as Jewish suffering Jewish
suffering has the same value as
Palestinian suffering If This Were A
Palestinian occupation and domination
the Palestinian genocide against Jews in
which there were nearly 8,000 precious
Jewish babies killed in 50 days we'd
have a qualitatively different
discussion qualitatively different
response and I believe Biden Harris
Austin we can go right down the line
Kirby blinkin they are complicities with
Israel's war crimes against the
Palestinians has Hamas committed war
crimes absolutely they committed war
crimes but not crimes of genocide and
when Nathan yahu invokes amalo Sam 1st
Samuel 15 and3 in the biblical text and
I speak as a Christian I know the
difference between those Divine sanction
genocidal commands kill every woman kill
every child in order to procure our end
he's invoked a number of times October
28th he's invoked am alock that's
genocidal intent and it's genocidal
attack flowing from that intent we have
to have a moral consistency across the
board every baby no matter who they are
the world have the same value let me go
to Eugene then your response to that I
mean you'll be aware Eugene that must of
the world is now watching with horror
the scale of Israel's response and when
they hear Netanyahu saying this isn't
going to stop until we've got rid of all
of Hamas and a best estimates they've
only killed six to 7 thousand Hamas
terrorists and that's just if you take
IDs word for it that means that 80% of
Hamas has not been eliminated yet how
many civilians are going to get killed
in the next few months or even years
before Hamas is eradicated and how in
the end does that help either peace in
the region or how does it stop just
massive escalation and radicalization
against
Israel so how many civilians will die is
largely a function of hamas's decisions
because Hamas has a specific strategy of
trying to kill as many Israeli civilians
as they can as they did on October 7th
and trying to get as many of their own
civilians killed which they do by hiding
in tunnels underpopulated areas basing
themselves in schools in hospitals their
strategy is to roll up their civilian
death toll which at the same time uh
Israel does everything to limit Israel
is only targeting Hamas now Hamas makes
it difficult by hiding among civilians
and the deaths of those civilians are
Hamas war crimes the accusations of
genocide it's what psychologists call
projection accusing your enemy the other
side of exact what you're doing to
distract and whitewash what you're doing
October 7th was a genocidal invasion of
Israel where Hamas invaded Israel
chopped up families in front of each
other burned people alive and now Israel
is responding more moderately than any
country would
let casualties let me put you on that in
terms of it's supposed moderate response
in the last few days alone we've seen
the IDF shoot dead three is Israeli
hostages who were wearing no shirts and
had a banner asking for help they were
Sur they were surrendering whoever they
were they turned out to be hostages then
we had two women uh innocent women
standing outside a Catholic Church who
were also Gunn down by IDF snipers in an
action that the pope called terrorism uh
you've also got President Biden
describing the bombing campaign as
indiscriminate which in itself that
description implies a war crime so this
idea that that Israel's being moderate
in its response I don't think is borne
out by reality is
it uh President Biden has actually said
and other American officials have said
that Israel is acting more morally than
any other Army now show me a war without
inadvertent civilian casualties when
America cleared Isis out of mosul 10,000
civilians were killed in that city alone
and America was not fighting an enemy
next door that was actively shooting
rockets at it and holding its citizens
hostage if Professor West had his way
Nazi Germany would still rule Europe
because of course hundreds of thousands
of German civilians died in the war
against Nazi German Confederacy would St
half let me bring okay let me hold on
and about the let me just say about the
hostages about the hostages because
that's a sensitive Point uh that's a
tragic incident of course and we could
we we saw today that the mother of one
of the hostages said she does not blame
the Israeli soldiers she Embraces them
because she knows that Hamas again is
responsible for their deaths because
Hamas has used every kind of subt to
trap Israeli soldiers fake surrenders
and suicide let me bring back in Corell
West Corell West the moral uh conundrum
here for many people is that what
happened October the 7th was utterly
horrific an appalling terrorist attack
on mostly absolutely civilian in
Precious he's a precious human being
here's my question here's my question
when you have Hamas stating since
October 7th we want to do that again and
again and again when it is their mission
statement to wipe out Israel and any
Jews who live in Israel when when we all
can see and hear them say this with
Brazen impunity what is Israel supposed
to do other than trying to remove
Hamas Hamas is very much like the Jewish
eron which is is a terrorist group
responding to vicious British
imperialism that killed innocent Arabs
every resistance movement against
colonialism domination and oppression
aparti like conditions you have
nonviolent streams you have nonviolent
streams the first Ani was nonviolent the
second one was primarily nonviolent only
with rocks and what did JFK said when
you make nonviolent Revolution
impossible you make violent revolution
inevitable you had to with the Jewish
earth going there's always been
terrorist expression the problem is the
IDF which comes out of jabotinsky which
was tied to the Jewish and terrorist
history and and this is the part of
Jewish history it's not all there's been
the Einstein and the Albert Magnus and
others who call for very different
things but when I hear my brother Eugene
say they've only killed the Hamas they
killed two Christian women in front of a
church a mother and a grandmother you
mean almost 8,000 children are being
shielded by Hamas do you really believe
the world is going to think think that's
serious these justifications are as weak
as pre Sweden Kool-Aid when we see the
massive suffering of precious
Palestinians who are innocent so this
notion that somehow you can continue to
lay put forward these lies though
brother Eugene the world is no longer
convinced and you know the Jewish
Community I've got to leave the debate
I'm sorry we run out of time I've got to
leave the debate there it's a
interesting debate uh passions run high
on both sides thank you both very much
for joining me Cornell I want to wish
you uh ongoing success with your uh
campaign in the presidential race The
Economist both of you Brothers both of
you Brothers I I pray for your families
and stay strong and let's try to hold up
A bloodstain Banner of some serious
morality and spirituality in a moment of
massive hatred and tribalism Y I would
in the name of Amos in the name of
Isaiah and in the name of Jesus I would
certainly agree with that but I was
going to read you a quote from The
Economist today we say Cornell West has
the Charisma and energy of James Brown
if the Godfather of Soul had also o gone
to graduate school and if that isn't
something you want to put on your
Tombstone one day Corner West you're mad
well that's not true James Brown is far
beyond me but I aspire to that kind of
movement and that F that kind of FK my
brother
absolutely it's great to see you and
thank you very much Eugene as well for
joining
me well on S next variety announcers
it's 100 best TV shows ever only one of
them is British can you guess which one
and why is it only one I'll debate with
someone from America who obviously got
dozens and dozens in there it's Tommy
Len
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well well trained most dog owners will
tell you a dog can turn you know what I
love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing Al in the
police to act without fear or Fai
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased new is
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man mous M
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a m St in
power and are there a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that welcome back to our sens joined now
by the host of out kcks Tommy lur and
his f the great Tommy Fearless lren
welcome to You Tommy um two things I
want to talk to you about one is uh this
bombshell news that the names of more
than 170 Associates of convicted sex
offender and obviously he's dead now
Jeffrey Epstein could be made public in
early January after a ruling from a US
judge including me here prince Andrew
but also another host of Rich famous
powerful people um this could be quite
devastating couldn't
it yeah I'll believe it when I see it
Piers I'd like to think that this is
actually going to be released but it
feels like we've been promised this for
so long and then there's always the
redactions there's always some reason
that this gets hidden and I'll tell you
this the names on that list and the
flight logs and everything involving
this there's a reason it's been hidden
so long it's because the elites that are
on it the elites that are connected to
it they are very nervous but they also
wield a lot of power Piers do you think
if it was a bunch of conservative talk
show hosts or Fox News personalities
that were involved in this or
potentially on a list do you think it
would be hidden for so
long if Donald Trump was on that list
the number of people who've been held to
account for for being around epsteam
when this stuff was going on is
miniscule compared to the numbers that
we know were flocking over to that
Island on his
plane right and a lot of these folks
claim they have no knowledge of all the
nefarious things going on the sex
trafficking the pros tion Rings they
claim they have no knowledge but I think
we all know that that's probably not
true so we need to see the names we need
full transparency here I don't know why
Elites and oftentimes liberal leftist
Elites go to such lengths to Shield
pedophiles and child Predators but it's
really becoming a trend and quite the
problem if you ask me well talking of
problems let's segue to what I think is
a grotesque problem which is variety
magazine has come out it's a Hollywood
Bible obviously has revealed his 100
best television shows of all time today
and there is one British show in the
entire 100 which is flea bag at number
82 almost all the others are American no
Monty Python no Faulty Towers no Brides
head Revisited no Downtown Abbey none
not even the original office there got
the American version but not the great
original one with Ricky jaes what is
going on here even you can't surely
pretend this is any way
genuine well I looked at the list and I
agree with some of it I disagree with
others but Piers you and I have talked
about this before we export culture over
to you guys in the UK we export all of
that and sometimes it's good and it's
great content and sometimes it's woke
crap so you have to take the good with
the bad but unfortunately we still do
rain Supreme when it comes to content
and entertainment love it or hate it I
am happy to say though that a lot of
these show well let me just say look
number three was shows on the list are
The Sopranos look I'll give you Sopranos
was great Mad Men number two great and
by the way the West Wing for me is the
greatest series of all time and that's
in there and that's great but Number One
I Love Lucy come on that's that's the
greatest TV show ever made
really no I I disagree with that
wholeheartedly Piers I think maybe your
show maybe up there on the list of
course our shows on the Fox News channel
I would put them on the list so I think
that maybe we need another list I am
happy to say though that a lot of these
shows on the list at least they're not
woke at least they're not about
transgender refugees of color somewhere
on an island you know that will probably
l in the next 10 years but as of now
talking of non-woke shows the one I
loved this year more than any other was
Yellowstone which is actually a
beautiful antidote against the woke
mindset and world it's set in cowboy
country it's brilliant you and I can
probably agree that Yellowstone is
brilliant
right Yellowstone is brilliant and as
somebody who comes from a ranching
family in Middle America I got to tell
you there's a reason why that stuff does
so well and even liberal audiences love
it unfortunately the all the Liberals
are also moving to Montana which we
don't necessarily
love I want to move to Montana I want to
buy a ranch in Montana tell me later we
run out of time great to see you uh see
you soon thank you very much
we're here thanks for joining us your
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all soon sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with soela braan she's heading up one
side and rich is soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadik Khan we're not stopping until
you stop
the amount of time it's taken the number
of illegal migrants currently sent by us
to Rwanda zil the amount of money it's
cost we're saying what are we saying
it's cost about 140 million £140 million
so far so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
him three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film